1 П О ти не один це Коли друг у СІЗО
Замініть його на посаду заступника голови
комітету фінансового управління справжня Дружба
друзі ви знаєте поки, що Ігор Валерійович
СІЗО, але я бачу, що справа його живе його
пітом продовжують подати пров мисця а Як
ж без них Це ж головне питання яке
сього верховний рад питання про де
мобілізацію військових та нема на це
години про Повернення койко друз нема на
це години - 20 на вулиці Хай сидять на траншеях
а від назначити Нового заступника голови
фінансового комітету до групи 1 plus1 Як
це мож Це ж просто яке знаєте спадкове
це група 1 +1 мати свого заступника в
цьому Комітет того разу дубинський якось
випавши СІЗО то Тод беремо василевс
смаглюк і ставимо на це місце